who as you may recall served at CDC
director during the Ebola and Zika
outbreaks dr. Frieden good morning I
want to go back to those projections
from the White House 100,000 to 240,000
dead in just this so-called wave of the
virus so the first question is how bad
is this going to get and would you
advise the White House in the same way
that the coronavirus advisors are right
at this moment right now this is
heartbreaking I'm in New York City where
the number of death deaths top 1,000
just in a few weeks it's a terrible
tragedy and unfortunately it will get
worse before it gets better
but each of us has within us the ability
to do a lot that turn the tide on this
there's much more that we can do as
individuals to support the health care
workers on the front lines and each
garment needs to do to get ready for
what's coming next
dr. Frieden would you be advising the
White House now to consider a federal
lockdown keeping people in their homes I
think we're missing the key point having
people stay at home is only one part of
what's essential and it is essential but
the other part is to get ready for what
comes next that means getting better
eyes on the virus understanding where
it's spreading and how it means
strengthening our health care system not
only so that we're ready for the
desperately ill patients but so we can
keep caring for people who have everyday
health problems and managing those who
have mild illness and most importantly
perhaps strengthening our public health
system which we've under invested in for
so long so that we can do the kind of
aggressive proactive supportive
contact tracing testing isolation
quarantine that other countries have
used to knock this down we can do it if
we work together dr. Frieden a lot of
Americans listening to you right now are
looking for some insight into when their
lives may get back to some kind of
normalcy the White House's projections
showed the virus descending into the
summer so can we look forward to
something in July or August that's
almost like normalcy
it's not like the weather we can't
expect seasons here
we have the future within our power look
at countries around the world that have
been able to tamp this down and then
gradually loosen the faucet and get back
to a new normal normal but a new normal
but not open the floodgates what does
that mean that means that people who are
over the age of 60 or who have
underlying medical problems may need to
stay home for longer but we should be
able to gradually reopen if we do the
right things it's not about the date
it's about the data are we strengthening
our health care system can we
proactively find every infected case
every contact and isolate them promptly
that's what Singapore Hong Kong places
of China outside of Hebei Province where
it all started that's what they're doing
and that's what we can do and must do to
reopen as soon and safely as possible
all right dr. Frieden thank you very
much an important reminder that those
projections are not up for sure think we
have the power to bend them down and we
are working to do so thank you again